our terminal one at reed international
airport it's a little more snug this
afternoon the drop off area is under
construction hundreds of pedestrian
safety bollards are being installed
there as hector mejia explains the work
could last a year
new construction and lane closures in
front of harry reid international
airport terminal 1. i was scared i
thought they were kind of dangerous
but it's all in the name of safety we
met kelly wimberly at the departure zone
where crews began installing more than
300 safety bollards this week dropping
off my best friends that came to visit
me
after 10 years
crews are currently blocking two traffic
lanes in front of the allegiant and
spirit ticket counters inside we found
sarah shirling waiting to fly out
everybody needs to allow more time
just
just for those little glitches
back outside these are similar to the
barriers installed on the las vegas
strip following a deadly dui sidewalk
crash back in 2015. i used to live in
cincinnati and they had the same problem
where someone ran into a bunch of
pedestrians this project is finally
underlay after a pandemic delay it's
broken up in seven phases moving south
over the next year as the concrete gets
dug up to replace some utilities then
we're going to lay down a new walkway
that's going to be a little bit more
durable and easier to sustain i've been
here for 30 years
and yes this is just slow today but this
airport gets really
congested in this area hector mejia live
local now